i share
all of your concerns for the environment
for the starving for the aids infected
for all the horror around us
but i also
believe nature has a higher wisdom than
any
of us can generate or bring to bear
and that in fact nothing is wrong
everything is on track
and that
we are in fact headed for extinction as
three-dimensional
animals
and that uh
and that's why shamanism and the archaic
revival and the discovery of the old old
knowledge knowledge which was useless
inside the enterprise of civilization
now has meaning because the enterprise
of civilization
is
finished and mercilead in another book a
book called myth dreams myths dreams and
mysteries has a wonderful passage where
he compares western civilization
to a dying
person
and he says when a person dies
their entire existence flashes
in front of them
and when it when a global culture dies
everything is flashing in front of us
every codex will be published every
archaeological site will be dug up and
displayed
every philosophy will be trotted out and
explored because we are in the delirium
that precedes transition
into the next dimension
and if we can through the use of
psychedelics
create
a shamanic understanding where
you know and i think that's what we're
doing that's what this circle is
but millions of people
billions of people
need
the
calming assurance
that comes
from experientially verifying
the existence beyond the grave
and i think that at the end of history
this is what will happen that very
shortly
the
the instability built into the system
is going to transform material existence
beyond all imagining
the culture the the global civilization
is dying there are too many problems
they're accumulating you have to be
blind to not realize that this is really
in fact the end of the road
and that it is um
you know the ozone hole the toxic
pollution the toxification of the ocean
we can't pretend that these things are
easily reversed by simply recycling or
something like that no
instead of this clutching
to keep it all like it is and say oh no
no please no future please no future we
have to say okay
deep breath it's like that first wave of
psilocybin when you feel it sweep over
you or ayahuasca and you realize you
know my god my god here it comes i've
done it this time well we've done it
this time folks we have been planning
human mass suicide for 15 000 years not
a moment
was not dedicated to this goal
and now it's upon us and it's a cause
for great rejoicing we will go off into
hyperspace
the planet will heave an enormous sigh
of relief
and if it can come back from an asteroid
impact that leaves nothing larger than a
chicken standing around then i dare say
in 50 60 000 years you know the glaciers
will run the jungles will re-stabilize
the ocean will cleanse itself and as the
itching says no blame
no blame
the metaphor that we have to keep in
front of ourselves you know you you all
know the cliche
uh ontogeny recapitulates phylogeny
right do we all understand what this
means no it's it means it's something
that embryologists in the 19th century
created and i think it's fairly profound
it's that
a fetus a human fetus
uh
recapitulates
the entire
history of evolution on this planet it
begins as a tiny one-celled organism it
becomes a fish it becomes a reptile it
becomes a mammal it becomes a human
being but the part of the recapitulation
of phylogeny that we've ignored is
extinction
for
for a million years we have been
uh
afloat
in the gentling amniotic ocean
of the planetary environment
imagine
the fetal crisis
of birth
you exist as a fetus inside your mother
food is delivered through the umbilical
cord oxygen delivered the same way
endless space
weightlessness
the dream
paradise all needs are met
and
then something begins to go wrong
the walls close in
the and you begin to be propelled into
the birth canal
strangulation
death
the fetus must know at that moment
incredible fear everything is going to
be destroyed the world is ending
yet how could the fetus
at that moment
imagine
hieronymus bosch or nuclear physics or
global politics or star flight or any of
these things
we are now in the birth canal
of a new
ontological order of human existence and
the walls are closing in there's no
going back the amniotic ocean the the
unpolluted
endless frontier of a game-rich planet
forget it we've been in the birth canal
for 10 15 000 years and now we're
approaching transition the most violent
part of the birthing process and
all you can do is screen
unless you have some superordinate
knowledge of what is going on
the shamans
shamans in the rainforest shamans
among us
and as a goal for each of us
must act as the midwives
to a new order of existence there's no
going back we've burnt this scene to the
ground and the womb is stretched the
womb is traumatized but it can recover
and but the the child and the mother
must be parted again the metaphor of
pregnancy if a pregnancy is
somehow
um doesn't if the birth is not smooth
if the child is not parted from the
mother
toxemia
sets in
and then both and then you have a real
crisis the life of the mother the life
of the child
everything is in danger this is the re
this is the real problem i don't think
we've reached that place yet i think
that we'll go fairly smoothly into
hyperspace but i think the emergence in
the last 20 years
of
masses of human beings taking
psychedelics masses of human beings
talking about
getting in touch with the spirit talking
about a new shamanism and archaic
revival this means we are very very
close to seeing the light at the end of
the tunnel and it's a radiance
the the the meaning and the depth of
which cannot be told because we are
after all being born into a higher
dimension but if we believe in the
dynamics of nature if we believe in the
rightness of being
then there should be no anxiety there
should be no alarm this is what
psychotherapy and shamanism and all
these things exist for is to spread the
truth about the situation so that we
don't clutch
and we don't hold on and spread panic
and hysteria
and that's what i've learned from
psychedelics
[Music]
you